back to you jaden yes thank you maurice
yeah interesting uh that
such a tame line uh came to
a boiling moment and and i
i'm with hikaru on this one as well by
the way uh
he felt after the move f five f four was
played
that suddenly well you know he may get
some chances and things could work out
quite well
and kasparov agreed with you so there
you go and then came
queen g6 and sc carl uh correctly stated
he can't overplay his hand otherwise he
was risking
losing the game and he made the prudent
choice the wise choice because he had no
choice he had to take the repetition
and with that after um that exciting
draw between
carlson and nakamura we are going to
take a little break and be back for the
finale of aronian kamsky
lovely
hey and welcome back to the sink field
cup we already have a result in today
the uh much awaited nakamura carlson
game was not quite as bloody
as we would have hoped but one nice
thing is that both players promised
excitement and an all-out fight tomorrow
oh yes um carlson said he was going to
try to win
try to press despite the fact that a
draw is likely going to secure first or
at least a tie for first right and uh of
course nakamura
knows he must win tomorrow with black
yes and both cases i think
we'll see both players go not recklessly
but all out um because uh the way
goddess
is played he's vulnerable even with the
white pieces as we've seen
and hikaru has won a number of their
key matchups remember in the u.s
championship oh yeah that's right he
needed to win with black that was a cool
game
and he got it and here is the prize
money breakdown we've got seventy
thousand dollars for first place
fifty thousand per second thirty for
third and twenty k
for fourth place now many people who are
good at math are going to figure out
who's likely to get fourth place
right unfortunately god has got a lock
on that it would appear
but okay we have this uh key position
and after some futzing around
rook b1 was played and the question is
is how god is going to
hold the position i was thinking that
ghada would likely play a move like
queen
f7
eyeballing this pawn on c4 i thought
that
you're not immediately threatening to
capture the pawn but bringing the queen
off the
back rank seems the most
likely move if i were white and i think
and i started thinking to myself i'm in
a situation let's just say
that i had to go all out for the win
this move e3 e4 is the
uh only lever that i have in the
position
a lever means like opening a door with
your pawn
exactly pulling up the e file and it
looks particularly logical with our
piece placement with our rook on e1 and
with the king being a little bit airy
now i wonder from moronian's point of
view he's got
um you don't even score now in order to
have a chance of winning this tournament
he has to win this game and not only do
they have to win this game he would
probably have to win with
he would have to win with black against
carlson that's a big ass is it even in
his mind or do you think he's just
playing the position
no he's definitely playing this position
and he's just hoping that he'll be in a
situation
where he's got an opportunity for
playing in the first place
his first half as we know was terrible
he
scored a a blunderful loss in round one
and then had two draws so he was
different the tournament would be like
if that because if that one move you
know it was going to be a draw
and then he just missed us one move
knight to d7 the tournament would be
totally different
right carlson would actually have a
dominating lead if it wasn't for that
exactly
and actually aronia would have a better
chance of of winning
exactly exactly that just one one move
in that one game
has made such an impact in the
tournament and it's so painful because
in a round robin as opposed to a swiss
tournament or something or
a match where you can kind of recover
and say that everything was different
and
really in a round robin it's like it
would have been pretty much the same
without a half point more yeah it's a
and it's a big half point these guys
claw for every inch and every half point
that is
that's what chess is about at the
highest levels
again just today in
reflection on the game you know we have
this grand
master draw in chess where the two grand
masters
really don't poke at one another and i
really had the feeling today that
magnus had just too easy at times i see
what you're saying i mean it's funny
because
when we talked about i on one hand i was
excited that
nakamura didn't go over the queen trade
line but in a certain way it's actually
more aggressive to play for the main
line
yes so it's like it feels less
aggressive because you're trading queens
but it's actually more aggressive
because it's more theoretically
viable and you know he's kind of testing
magnus in the main waters rather than
going for an offshoot in which case
magnus is much more likely to uh you
know find a comfortable
equality or close to equality that being
said
magnus didn't think was such a bad idea
so yeah well he
obviously yeah he's biased well yes
exactly well in his particular case he
did confess
that he had a little trouble with this
particular
approach that um
hikaru took today but then he just
looked at the games of vladimir kramnik
and said
okay that's the way i'm supposed to deal
with it that's the way i will deal with
it
and if it was good enough for vladimir
kramnik it was good enough for magnus
carlsen
all right and we have a grandmaster
maurice ashley with some thoughts of his
own
yes jen just reflecting on your thoughts
about aronian
remember aronian was under terrific
pressure
against magnus carlson he could have
easily lost
that game as well and that would have
been a serious disaster for him and an
even more dominant
performance for magnus so maybe he's
counting his lucky stars
that he's able to stave off defeat in
that game
and now on the with the opportunity
anyway of maybe being able to defeat
godikomski and he's actually still in
reach
of winning the whole thing also don't
forget there's a big difference between
second place
and third place in terms of the prize
money it's fifty thousand to
thirty thousand so ending up in second
place anywhere
near second uh will be very good for him
so he wants to win
today and i suspect he's gonna try real
hard for that
there's something else i'd like to point
out we talked about this very early on
just in the very first few minutes of
the game
the time situation godakomski now down
to 15 minutes
for approximately 14 more moves now
of course he can pull it off we've seen
that top grand masters at this level
do this all the time but with his
lack of form it might prove critical in
the last few minutes of this time
control
and certainly lavonne will want to keep
up the pressure in this situation
to kind of help his opponent help him
to win the game back to you jen and yaz
help me to help you i like
it we've got a couple comments coming
into our hashtag
sync cup somebody asked about um the
link to buy the beautiful chess pieces
the dgt
enabled the house of staunten pieces
here made specifically
for the sing field cop and i did post
that link on us chess twitter so
you can go ahead and find them and it
only will set you back thirteen hundred
dollars
actually 12.95 a bargain a bargain
uh i just happen to know how much effort
and work goes
into their their really masterfully uh
crafted sets
really really beautiful oh it's art
right it is and the world house of hall
of fame argues that as well and uh
they definitely have some pieces that uh
will cost
quite a lot more than uh twelve hundred
dollars we've got some of those irises
they're just
gorgeous oh yeah the ancient in the crew
miller
exhibition that's up now fabulous we
also uh we also got a comment
about how the carlson game was uh
perfectly
timed um that's from our our friend
tarjay svensson who's been tweeting at
us
a lot during this tournament and uh he
said that
he gets to watch real madrid get beaten
up in la liga
so a soccer reference um thanks carson
of course
a big sports fan but especially soccer
yes
well norway and europe soccer is the
world's number one sport we did have
this move queen f7 by gatakamsky again
i've been suggesting that white's
main line of play is to get in this
freeing break e3 e4
and in that case the rook on the fir on
e1
would be attacking the queen so this
move queen f7
dodges that potential bullet while
setting up
an opportunity of capturing this pawn on
c4
that's not an immediate problem and with
the move queen d2
lavone basically says okay i am still
aspiring uh to play the move e3 e4
and there is no threat you can't capture
this pawn on c4
because of this absolute pin which would
cost you
your queen for a bishop so that is not
a threat but in the future this pawn is
hanging
black could make an effort with the move
king g7 to set that up as a potential
um capture but not in the immediacy
right so you're expecting king g7 i
think that king g7 is a is about as
reasonable a move as any in the position
uh basically from goddess point of view
he still he hasn't given up on this idea
of one day playing h5
h4 and if his king were on g7 he could
slide his rook over to h8 to make that
possible that's right so unlike white
his king is kind of
kind of stuck there in g1 i mean we
could play king f1 and e2 to play rook
h1 but then our pawn on g2 would be
pretty tender so instead we will
probably keep
ours but king g7 rook h8 h4 is a serious
uh surprising move queen
f six by ganakamsky basically saying
take the pawn on h5 i dare you
and if you don't by the way i'm setting
up a bishop c3
kind of uh pit skewer that's right
to go after the rook let's just take a
quick look at what in the world
god has in mind in case of knight takes
h5
i'm assuming the same move that we had
seen
earlier would still apply in this case
queen h6
chasing the knight back to f4 so white's
a pawn up but
look at this open h file rook
witch rook one of them rook d7 or rook
f7
pleasant choice and you're setting up
for
the for a mating idea of rook h
well this is really interesting because
if we play something like king to f1
to try to you know at some point if we
play king f1 to try to get away from it
you might be able to lock it in with a
weird looking move like bishop f3
and in case of takes takes this
threat of queen h1 checkmate
is very very lucky for white he does
have this queen d5
to get rid of that f3 but if not for
that he would be losing so that is the
type of
tactical opportunity that
gada would be looking for so how's this
for a different approach for for lavone
after we reach this position could i
at all essay this crazy move
e e3 e4 allowing
my king to be exposed
a very dangerous double-edged play by
aronian if he were to allow this
and a very messy position indeed yeah um
but has gotta calculated it accurately
though
because if the attack doesn't work it
will backfire in fact and it's not just
a question of missing
but missing really really badly so much
so that white might end up
in uh frankly a winning position
so um although we could take on e4 here
as well
so we don't actually have to take a
check right away
because now there's going to be
something hanging on a v1 at the end of
this variation very good
so we would start with we would we
wouldn't start with queen h1 check
remove order is always really important
because then king e2 would actually
attack the queen
exactly but rather captain e4 first you
know queen h1 and uh
not a good episode to take my rock
true king would have to step up
and that would leave the rook
unprotected
and that would be winning for black no
question about that one
okay we'll go back there's some danger
here for lavon oroneon but
we're just looking about the capture
casters on h5
right he has other options indeed detail
so let's see after queen f6
what other possibilities might he
consider i was just
loving oh you want to continue yeah i
was just loving the pond grub for a
moment but
okay besides that he could play
a quiet defensive move simply bringing
his rook up to b3
and and for stalling
that threat of bishop c3 by the way now
that the rook is on b3
that variation we just played through uh
the rook would not be a target in that
case
and here i suppose gada would go for
a similar idea of rook d7 followed by
rook h7
still playing for the h5
h4 uh king side attack
yeah look v3 is kind of awkward though
doesn't it it's like
okay it's it's not the greatest rook
we've ever had rook b3 i know you've
been trying to play e4
all game mm-hmm well unfortunately
again e5 before three i was looking to
see if something like
somehow i could make that work but i
don't think so yeah because
at age five bishop takes d2 uh knight
takes f6 and in the end
black is up a piece precisely
two bishops for black a single bishop
for
white winning position for black in
that case so bishop c3 is serious
uh maybe we should just simply get our
rook out of the way
but then why did we play rookie one
earlier
you've been trying to play e4 for so
long that would really cut your chances
precisely annoyingly so another idea is
to play something like knight d5 do you
think he's considering that
yes after knight d5 giving black the
opportunity of going into
uh bishops of opposite color probably he
would decline that opportunity
tip your head and say you've got a nice
night that you still
haven't addressed how you're going to
deal with
h5 and h4 you've just got a good knight
for the moment
that's true yeah i agree i like the move
queen g5 or knight and her knight
doesn't uh do anything massive right now
and we still can't play e4 because that
moved queen g5
is actually as actually pinned upon as
it turns out
so the knight is going to stay on f4 so
we're
we're contemplating either rook b3 rook
d1 and let me get a
because we are getting concerned about
the clock
11 minutes 12 minutes for gotta 24
for aronian still nothing serious in
in the way of time trouble nothing
serious but there could be some
interesting decisions for ghada as we
play the next 13 moves and uh you know
he's not going to be able to go into a
tank for any of them
exactly you'll have to play quite
quickly in fact
hmm so again difficulties for our
commentators as we
uh struggle to understand how uh
the vonaronian is going to
put pressure on u.s champion gotta
kamsky here
that's right i mean it's starting to
look pretty decent for uh
fregatta yes and just a
lot of strange moves here queen d1
queen d2 bishop c2
not too impressed by this i know it's
probably not what aronia is going to
play but let's give this
whole line of play once
once more another look yeah another look
just to
because it's it's rather critical
how is a position as silly as
this looking like
now he in this case white's king is
going for a walk
and it looks like all i've managed to do
is invite the white
the black king pardon me black queen
pardon me
uh into a very powerful
attacking position i don't see anything
like a happy position for black yeah i
don't see any benefit whatsoever
uh for white here so this
line of play really doesn't inspire that
can't be played so
and once more do i see we kind of need
at least at least we kind of want the
knight on f4 to
to protect you too for the time being
right even though there
are some tactics um as you pointed out
a lot of times the bishop f3 sacrifice
could just be met by
capture capture queen d5 jack because of
the poor position of the black king for
the moment so
right maybe we could but if we play the
problem if we play king f1 then he
he just switches up the move order on us
again and takes on f4 and then plays
queen to h1 jack
and so that's the problem we've been
having right
and once again um
we would really like to remove the
bishop on c6
true i was just trying to
fathom whether this is but this is crazy
my king was nice safely tucked away
and suddenly in this position in the
middle of the board i mean all i am
is inviting a horrendous uh
attack by black so i just don't think
i think the pawn on h5 is
poisonous and i simply can't grab it as
as desirable as it is the problem is
that if we don't take the pawn the
black's going to get an attack as well
so right and if i do and damned if i
don't right
that's why you know we're trying to look
for some kind of so after queen f6 let's
take a
we've tried knight takes pawn we've
tried rook b3
and you also have rook d1 sliding over
but in
those cases where i'm not capturing the
pawn
this idea of breaking up
white on the king side is
more than just annoying yeah it just
doesn't look pleasant at all
so maybe this move queen d2 is just
simply wrong
and levon has missed that opportunity
that he had to play e3 e4 earlier
just to go back a few moves to show what
i meant i believe it was around
these parts that i was
stumping for e4 or maybe it was actually
back oops i went too far apologies
in any case let's just look at what's
the situation
that aronian is facing there is a
twin threat in the position for black
gotta kamsky threatening bishop c3
securing an exchange as well as h5
h4 and lavon has got to come up with
something
extra special here in this position
else he's going to be in trouble yeah
this move queen six is
is great i love this move kind of
just a double attack really right but a
weird devil attacking that you know
bishop c3 is
is a clear attack and h4 is more of a
positional
precisely positional idea and just just
unexpected double attack a great move
okay hmm i
i'm frustrated by
my inability to get in well
to capture the pawn as well as to get in
this move e3 e4
so let's just see if if
lavonna ronian allows uh
black this opportunity of getting in
h5 h4 are there any
chances of perhaps being able to use
this rook
to to go along the site this looks very
dangerous for white though it looks to
me like
white's king is in more trouble yeah
than
blacks you can you can capture on g3
here and
well this was where i i'm a little bit
worried that my queen is going to be in
a pin
yeah exactly i wanted to go here
and then i was thinking queen g5 could
be in the air as well
and precisely i'm attacking you twice
and i'm ready to take on e4
and add another attacker to f4 so this
looks pretty
scary yeah this looks disastrous there's
no question this looks like
uh just simply no can do well out of
nowhere
the honoroneon and some under some
pressure here you know hunkering down
he's been thinking for quite a while in
this position i think
he must have had something in mind and
underestimated the danger
or perhaps even missed the move queen to
f6 because it's
it's pretty uh pretty brilliant well
yeah it's a sly
way of getting in a double attack with
the queen when the queen was on
e8 and not bothering anybody
i think levone had basically um
put away out of his mind this uh
attacking move h5h4
now that he's suddenly facing it once
again he's going why on earth did i
allow this double attack
and um now he's under pressure
yeah so lavender and digging deep to try
to find some way to defend here
we've been getting lots of comments uh
to our hashtag sync cup
uh thanks for chiming in and we hope you
all join us tomorrow
too for a couple hours earlier and we've
got daniel wrench from chess.com
and he said according to chess mic every
bar in the city
is showing the chess match the singfield
cup chess match turning away
college football fan i know that awesome
and i don't know judging from the number
of ex-clams it's possible that that
tweet's hyperbolic
but i love it i i'll take claim to that
me too
that's why louis has overtaken football
we couldn't
we didn't think this day would come so
soon but here we are
in the central west end we started from
the bottom which is
now all over all over you love it
but it's true that i i was at uh i was
at the
sub-zero which is right next door the
sushi bar and um i saw
i saw the chest chest on fox sports
midwest and everybody at the table just
started screaming
cool other people have been playing what
are they screaming about
oh those exciting queens indians man
they just really get your blood boiling
they do they do and grandmaster maurice
actually has a comment for us
on chess being replaced by football
no no
that's not gonna happen anytime soon you
know when i go
to the games i remember being at the
rams game earlier this week on sunday
where the players got to go on the field
and also at the
st louis cardinals game where infield
threw out the first pitch
and the players were on the jumbotron i
really felt like chess had arrived i
mean it's a very nice moment
for us as chess fans to get that kind of
recognition in that
kind of realm i always fantasize when
i'm in a stadium like that
of seeing chess on the big screen in
that way in a big stadium
with 50 000 fans going crazy but i'm
not sure our sport can possibly get to
that level
we'll see with all these initiatives
here in st louis but for now
i'm sure college football is quite
secure
back to you shannon yes well
football for chess to be much bigger
than it is now so
exactly i mean chess has had a very very
difficult time after the days of bobby
fischer
when bobby fischer withdrew from chess
from the 1972-1992 period
and actually you know in thinking about
it the biggest
chess matches in the united states were
somehow
they always involved gary kasparov uh
the deep blue match
his match with veswanathon demand in
1995
his match with anatoly karpov in 1990 in
new york
so really it's been either bobby fisher
or gary kasparov that has inspired chess
on tv but it's nice
that well maybe magnus will bring it up
there he certainly looks good on camera
he does he does he does
and i look and we have another thought
from our ease
well i just like to jump to the game we
have not been really paying attention to
the
clock as closely as we need to because
levon aronian after this move queen to
f6 has gone into
a hyper deep think and if you look at
the clock times now
he's down to seven minutes and 16
seconds
and counting down this move queen of six
has really shocked him remember we
talked about kamsky
being at a time disadvantage but it is
erroneous now with the deficit on the
clock
wikomski at 12 15. they still have to
make 13 moves now remember
he's getting 30 seconds back in
increment every move he makes
so 13 moves times 30 seconds six and a
half minutes so he really has
over 12 minutes left in the game but
it's still 13 moves
in a situation where he is under heavy
attack and he has in fact
captured the pawn on h5 daring kamsky
now
to attack him he has ripped off the pawn
after
all that thought this game is about to
get wild and both sides
in some interesting time pressure at the
moment back to you jen and yaz
wow this game is just getting super hot
just as they're
reaching 40th move which is treacherous
for them but thrilling for us so
please don't go away we are getting some
comments uh chestnut network uh tweeted
at sync
sync cup that the c6 bishop is the mvp
of this game
it strikes at g2 it observes the weak
point at d5
and it prevents any rook invasion on the
seventh rank and that's one of the
reason why
both uh grandmaster jasser sarwan and
gary kasparov
are always so fond of those two bishops
right because of points like this it can
it can do defense and attack so much
better
at the same time as a nightcan exactly
now
when we had gone through our analysis
jen
very reluctantly i must add i had to
come to the conclusion that
that pawn on h5 was poisonous
and our main mind was
queen h6 attacking the knight i didn't
see
any choice from white's point of view
but he had to
slip back with the knight and then i'm
not a hundred percent sure which rook
but
i went with rook d seven feels right
because if you move the other rook to h7
then f5 might be hanging in the
variation
that's right so rook d7 and now
white is facing this obviously powerful
threat of a battery and the queen is
about to invade
down the h-file now how black white's
king
is going to escape the threats it's not
going to be easy
i mean how is he going to do that maybe
he should play
the movie we looked at e4 and then we
talked about rook h7
king and one it looks like we have some
more moves in
oh no i think we're about to get more
moves and give us a sec
right so after after king f1 we were
looking at uh take some e4
and this was maybe where instead of
hanging this rook on b3 on b1 pardon me
i need well i'll tell you what
i'll tell you you want to try refreshing
the board all right let's
let's do that let's refresh and just get
up to date
okay yeah so now we're on time right the
times
are 20 24 to 12. no no no there
we got them right here in the on the
board right here we got seven and a half
seven minutes and 50 seconds for our
onion and uh
12 minutes for gotta cam's game and i
believe we have seen queen
h6 and i believe we have seen knight f4
so we're looking at the move rook d7 so
now
now kamsky's thinking about the most
accurate way here to bring a rook
into the game to do a little mini rover
yes
rook up just a little bit all right
well here i mean i'm flummoxed because
i really don't like doing something
desperado like
f2 f3 that just that feels all wrong to
me
i mean but maybe
maybe here white could look for some
salvation but
definitely it's in black's favor oh that
looks sad that's pretty terrible
it does and if we i i really wish we
could trade off those those bishops if
we could get a stake in the uh
the position with our bishop on c2 but i
can't figure out a way to do it because
you know what if our queen was on d1 we
would have the nice little
rejoinder here bishop a4 right which
would which would be so
clutch at this exact moment but you
don't have it
and this bishop on c2 is a very passive
bishop
and again then i'll agree with the
twitter feed comment that the bishop on
c6 is the all-star for black in this
position
and maybe it's just time to get on our
horse and start running
yeah we tried that before and still that
didn't okay we didn't like that we
didn't like that they could just take on
f4 and play queen h one shot queen takes
g2 and it just looked uh
pretty terrible yeah okay so let's
give it another uh look-see how about
rook b3
rook h7 so you're obviously you've got
this
uh terrible threat of checkmate in one i
have to
run like rabbit and now how are you
going to kill me jack
um just take on f4 or sorry yeah
probably i was going to just take on f4
and then take on h1 because
as you pointed out earlier bishop f3
didn't quite do the job
well here was the reason why i brought
the rook up
because i'm hoping that after a move
like queen takes g2
well i don't see anything better than
rookie but this is just a free attack
for for black in fact you may just have
a checkmate
after all something like this
this check and one of our favorite mates
oh very nice probably you would have had
to run over to d3 instead somewhere in
that variation but that wouldn't be
pretty too then you would just lose all
your whole second rank yeah the cons
would start dropping like flies
yeah and you've got to look at it looks
like that is about to play with d7 i
sense that
looks like he's he's reaching he's
reaching for a movie we see here on the
webcam
and and what did he play he's already
played rook d7 and he switched his rook
all the way across to the h7
right you have this so we so we have
rook d7
and now what move after rook d7
knight d5 was played okay okay so we
thought that knight d5 might occur as
well so you've got to bring that rook
back from b3
exactly well after work to d7 we have
knight to d5
and then rook swings over our patented
check
made in one threat can we pattern that
nobody else never kicked me nobody else
could check mate like us
and we've got grandmaster maurice ashley
for some time
in the commentary well jen the game
is definitely heating up and it's
getting crazy in here right now
it looks as though the computer has
decided that aronian is actually only a
tiny bit worse
and has a forcing line that basically
invites the white queen
the black queen in only to expel it a
few moves later
take a look at this line i'm not sure if
this he wants is what he wants to play
but the move knight d5 as he has played
and now rook to h7
and now this shifty king move queen h1
check
and king up to e2 and then queen takes
g2
and now a move i'd be terrified to play
rook g1
allowing this check and the king
dropping back to f1 and you see this
queen is posted up in a fantastic
position
but it is also trapped in white's camp
this moves like bishop d1 followed by
bishop c2 the queen really can't escape
under good circumstances the suggestion
by the computer is rook to h2 allowing
this move knight e7 check
king up and then knight takes and this
is how you eliminate this bishop
and then quite possibly just play queen
d5 to try to shut
all of the action down after a trade
black does have a strong bishop
and this past pawn but looking at it
it's hard to see how white would
actually win this position
i mean black would actually win this
position from here because this pawn is
always going to be under pressure
the rook has the b file the king can go
to e2 at some point in the game
and it looks like white probably would
be able to save this position
so hold your horses erroneous not quite
dead yet
it looks as if there might be a method
to his madness jen and yaz
i don't know i think that that he
couldn't have wanted to go by to this by
choice
i think he found the best defense out of
necessity
right otherwise he wouldn't have gone in
the tank so so so long after queen have
sex
right i think it was just that queen f6
did unnerve him and exposed
uh this this twin thread of bishop c3 at
h5h4 he underestimated in the final
position that maurice
brought to our attention it's quite true
that
white has good defensive chances but for
any
of the people in the audience who play
benoni defense
this would be a dream position for
anybody who plays the benoni
only two results possible black to win
or draw i i like black's chances very
much
hard to win hard for ghada to win yes
but would he try
and you can see him yes actually pretty
confident today at the board
sometimes you see him with his face in
his hands but here he he looks
he looks pleased yeah well is that a pl
is that a look of pleasure i'm not
confident i would say confident all
right let's go back to
uh let me refresh the board so we can
get a
chance of the times and they have
followed the analysis
thus far queen takes g queen takes g2 i
beg your pardon
and this kind of hard hard to fight move
rook g1 although again because it's
maybe
necessary maybe not all that difficult
queen f3 check marisa is mentioning king
f1
and after the move rook h2
also in this case suggested by the
computer putting pressure on this pawn
this was how we got that variation
and knight went down checked and
traded itself for uh that
terrible mvp that light-squared bishop
that's right i mean worked
on that that's a little good defensive
fine here by
lavon yes did he play he spent he spent
time yeah
he did play it you know he spent time at
it to take it on age five because you
know he's gonna be losing if he doesn't
have that move and that's why he went
you don't see players of the elite level
going to that kind of tank
that often right they tend to be
managing their time pretty well
exactly and here it it proved that he
was right to do it
well it would just be the the cruelest
of
ironies if in this position
for the third time in the tournament
where ghada was
really going on the attack and pressing
and he did it against
again carlson you know f5 g5 g4 h5 he
was
he was throwing the paddies and then
against
nakamura he too was on the attack
and again with aronian so please got it
don't lose this game
i mean he'll he'll stop attacking for
the rest of his life
if he were to lose this game so after
rook g1
not too much of a choice here queen f3
check
king f1 and now maybe if i was black
i would just try to find another move
that wouldn't necessarily allow 97.97
but the question is do i have anything
stronger
than rook h2 at the moment and is there
like a is there some kind of perpetual
threat here as well i mean your queen
doesn't really have a lot of squares to
go to is the issue
well okay let's say i just made made a
move for arguments like rook f7
random move you can't perpetual you
can't hit me right away because c4
would be hanging yeah yeah with check
exactly
and that's a bit of a problem so right
but what marie said was really annoying
in in its truthfulness in the fact that
black's queen is actually trapped it's
not gone anywhere i mean
so right so you could maybe even it's
frustrating for the second player
when you get a circumstance like that
yeah maurice
well you know i like to read body
language as well and if you look at the
table godda looks determined but
aronian is walking around i mean he
doesn't
seem as if he's scared he's terrified
it's pretty clear to him and look at him
walking completely away from the board
now
out of camera shot it's pretty clear to
him
that there's probably no mate
i mean he's casually looking at the
score sheet walking around
saying you've got no attack i'm not
worried about this
if you want to trade off the knight for
your light squared bishop would i
which i've just essentially plugged out
of the game then the opposite color at
bishop attack is probably not going to
work since he secured
all those key squares around his king
and god is looking now trying to figure
out
what do i have really i mean i chased
his king out of the middle
and there's no mate and he might have to
just
accept the fact that the mating attack
is not there
and trades are about to happen which
might simply equalize the game and here
he is
thinking in this moment remember the
time pressure is still there for both
players
so let's see how this proceeds got a
needing
to not lose at least if he loses this
like you said yes he's never attacking
ever ever again back to you guys
true don't tell that we don't want the
kids at home to lose three games and
then stop
playing cats exactly uh it's
frustrating all right so if i'm in
kamsky's shoes here
i really don't like okay that benoni
ending with opposite color bishops makes
sense after rook h2 but if i were
um in goddess shoes i'd sure give this
move king g7 a deep glance
the idea here is just a side step and we
do have that move
so we do yes seven has been played okay
just sidestepping that track and you
know another
but there is this a weird variation
let's say white played 97 anyway
and i was just looking at some strange
looking line
after bishop e4 bishop d1 just to show
that uh the queen isn't that the queen
can be trapped but it that's not the end
of this story here jen
uh i do have this move queen
h1 with our old favorite threat
of capturing the rook and checkmate
and what's your idea if i and if i take
right away you're just getting
both of my rooks this is a case of take
my rooks yes that's right
and and now we've got a just uh two
pieces for
we've got two books for the queen after
the night extricates itself
one day uh and yeah don't go
too far because uh yeah it looks
dominating for the rocks here
uh well gee uh i'm still
kind of confused still i i'm guessing
moves like queen
here with ideas like this
bishop here queen here
okay so you got some counter play going
as well but i i get
a bishop f3 check in here oh that's a
good one
uh good one indeed you get to take a
bishop with check
and i'm i'm
hoping for some kind of uh a draw by
repetition
still looks like i should be able to get
out somewhere yes exactly
yeah you would be robbed if you you
would feel robbed
if you didn't uh win this i understand
you're also attacking f5 so
so it's a little bit it's messy that's
for sure a lot of these variations are
quite messy
well let's uh let me refresh the board
and get it get a look at the times
and six minutes six minutes has
definitely heated up
well just six moves to the time control
as well
and we do have queen d1 on the board
queen d1
so white has offered a trade of queens
understandably
he wants to try to trade queens in this
position you can't really blame him
not one bid so this move king g7 was
probably a little bit more useful than
the move rook
h2 and now there's really nothing
god can do to avoid this trait of queens
probably he's simply going to have to
swallow his pride
and trade queens in order not to get a
weakness
uh a weak pawn on the f3 square and can
he make
anything out of this position still
uh though from goddess point of view
he's the one pressing
here i like uh
black's position so you like his
activity a lot but those those some of
the pawns really um you can't make any
levers as you like to say
yes so you're this is all about peace
activity and work activity it's not
about
trying to uh queen upon or something
like that
clear and uh what are your thoughts on
this
maurice well it seems that aronian miss
an opportunity to
stop suffering i mean maybe he thinks he
can still win i don't know
but as queen d1 i agree with yuyas is
just allowing black to have
a very safe very simple advantage but he
had another move
that could have really made god a sweat
and wonder if he could have possibly won
this position
instead of playing queen to d1 he could
have challenged
the black queen with the move rook to b3
and now suddenly the move e4 is showing
up with threats to the queen
and this would have been quite dangerous
the best response
for gada would have been to take on d5
and then after excuse me and after
taking back
on d5 gotta could play the move c4
and this could lead to the line bishop
d1 queen e4 and i know we hate it
but a straight repetition of moves as a
line and that could have led to a draw
if
he had found those moves so it looks as
though aronian had an opportunity to
squelch all of black's activity
kill the position and save himself any
more suffering
but has chosen to do a different path
which definitely looks
slightly better for black back to you
guys
that's that's a tough line to find
especially with not a lot of time on the
clock
true although it would have been kind of
cool to have uh both of our games today
be bishop repetition
ambitious repetitions that would there
would have been some irony for sure
queen d1 i expected queen takes d1
and so forth and so on ghada has played
bishop takes d5
so giving up one of those beautiful
bishops well it was the mvp
and we are ending up in that bononi
ending
let's say after a move like queen takes
d5
queen takes d5 c takes d5 black
is for choice thanks to the fact that he
has a pass pawn
in the position whereas white does not
right unlike the other line where
we were talking about how it wasn't as
much about pawn but more about the
possibilities of attacking with those
two bishops that's
it and now the question is after king f6
if white just decides to hold the ship
steady
play a move like king e2
at the moment this rook on the b
file as an excellent file this rook on
the
h file is excellent offsetting rooks
bishops of opposite color
no the main edge is the main edge for
black is just that that c
pawn and the the nicely placed king that
might go to e5 at some point right
but is it enough at this level
because remember if rook's ever come off
the board then it's just yeah yeah
then it's going to be a dead draw so i
think i think uh
i think it's hard to see how black's
going to
create something from this like what
would your plan be as black i know this
is one of your expertise
trying to squeeze blood from a song and
sometimes succeeding
a little a little maneuvering yeah how
are we going to get our pieces
what would you do if i just put my
bishop from d1 to c2 what's your dream
here
are you going to try to get your king on
e5 somehow right i'm not saying
i can set up my dream position i'm not
even sure what my dream position might
be by the way
yeah but something along the lines of
bishop c3
and getting my king to e5 would probably
be a very good
start if i could win that pawn for free
well then we could start talking but
it's going to be
really uphill battle to win that pawn
for free yeah that's going to be hard
because i can always just stick a rook
under you on and then
how do you uh continue attacking and i
mean that's one of the reasons why
because of opposite color in the end
game are drawlish because
we it's difficult to pile up enough
pressure on one point
precisely like after for example
something like rook h1
trade a pair of rooks and get a position
like
this the king
could just set up a station a blockading
station pardon me
on the c4 square and i just don't see
winning chances here i think this is a
draw not
even a suffering one actually the king
will just be very good here
so i don't really see a good
way for god to press you like the
structure for black but you don't seem
to
well the difference is is that if i if
this rook
for argument's sake was over here on b6
and maybe i had opportunities like rook
a6 and
and utilizing this pawn by being able to
play c
four c three and putting a rook on b2
sure like we saw
in got a kansas game with magnus carlson
he had that
wonderful past pawn on the seventh rank
there's something there but this is such
a long way from getting there and we do
have some moves coming in so instead of
maneuvering that king to e2 it looks
like there's um
a massive trade on h1 being arranged all
right it should be
even more rawish oops
i uh and maurice and we've gotta grab
master maurice ashley with his thoughts
on this
uh yuck what can i tell you this
position is obviously
dead drawn now obviously the highest
level when you play
great chess when both sides attack well
defend well
then the games will end in draws as much
as we despise it
particularly as american fans where
everything has a tie break
whether it's football goes into overtime
whether
it's baseball going into extra innings
the same name of basketball
even hockey which can sometimes have
ties but of course you get the shootout
at the end
we really don't like to see draws but
it's not as though these two players
tried to play for a draw in fact they
really tried to attack especially in
this case godakovsky trying to get a win
aronian had to defend himself against a
surprise move
queen to f6 and it just looks like the
position has petered out and also
aronian's chances of
possibly taking first place will simply
disappear in this moment as well he
won't have
that much to play for tomorrow which
would be to
to magnus carlson's benefit for sure
but remember ikaru can still
catch magnus in the event of a draw if
he beats godakomski
so this tournament is still up in the
air lots to play for
but it looks as though this game will
certainly peter out into
a pretty simple looking draw and we've
made
move 40 and they're continuing to play
moves both of them are playing quite
rapidly
and i think lavon uh is
neither of them are offering a draw
lavon perhaps thinking that uh because
of
camsku's superior structure here it's uh
the onus is on kamsky
to offer the draw would you would you
say that's actually that's right that's
right uh
white should not uh and they have and
they have offered a draw
and the game both games today here at
the singfield cup have been drawn we saw
a really bloody day yesterday and today
um peace broke out um but uh not with
without tons of fighting chess along the
way
it was a deserved piece i think it was a
good these were
this was a good round of play i liked
uh this game uh especially and i think
gotta feels a little bit relieved
solid draw with black area was on the
upper hand of that
um and it's nice to see him smile so
still in last place in this tournament
but definitely showing
his chops in this game with that really
well-timed queen to f6 move which almost
rattled lavon and especially the point
which was in the clock and the time
control that really could have toppled
him over
well lesser grandmasters could have
easily lost that position with white
uh rook g1 was just a fine move and it's
a
it's ironic that black didn't have more
after that
right and just seeing rook to one much
earlier and then just like snatching the
pawn and knowing this is the critical
moment if i screw up now right i could
lose the game and that would be
embarrassing so
well never mind embarrassing it's sad
sad exactly
and we've got grandmaster maurice ashley
with some thoughts as we wait for the
players to come down and be interviewed
well again you know i like to look at
body language and it really looked as
though
komsky wasn't just relieved he was
almost happy i mean it's
odd because this draw also pretty much
cements
his last place finish the best he can do
even with a win tomorrow i think is
to tie lavon aronian for the bottom half
if
lavonne actually loses tomorrow so
be interesting to find out his thoughts
there on only drawing the game and
feeling uh
what would look like he was kind of
happy lavon on the other hand has to be
disappointed with this result he
started off the tournament with such a
whimper with a horrible blunder
and now his chances have simply dried up
completely
to win the tournament he can only play
for pride if he can maybe
beat magnus tomorrow but he'll have a
tall order with the black pieces
certainly though nakamura will be going
for it
full boar he has absolutely nothing to
lose almost i mean maybe if he loses the
game
and aronian could only tie him with a
draw so
expect to see a definite bloody fight
between the two
americans oddly enough in the last round
of the sink field cup
jennings just to be clear
at the moment magnus is plus two and
lavonne is
even right so we've got three and a half
for magnus
three for nakamura two and a half for
lavonne
and one forgotten camps game right well
just to postulate for a moment
if lavonne were to win and
godakamski were to win then tomorrow we
would have a two-way tie for first
between lavon rooney and and magnus
carlson
and they would be in an overtime game
right
wait a second wait no no no and tomorrow
magnus and lavon and ronian are going to
be playing
right and if you're right if oh you're
saying also defeats
nakamura right but if iranian wins
ironian wins that pulls him up to plus
one
while dragging magnus down to plus one
so we still have
we still have a chance to win situations
here absolutely
or uh both of our opponents are the
black pieces tomorrow
so right um pretty uh pretty thrilling
indeed
and uh we are now getting ready for
our first interview and with the u.s
champion go to camps yeah and i'll
remind you guys again tomorrow 11 a.m
local 12 eastern
two hours don't tune in at the regular
time or you'll miss a lot of the fun
and uh we do have grandmaster maurice
ashley with our u.s champion
gotta kampski playing a very interesting
game today against
lev aronia
thanks jen and thanks yas for pointing
that out thank goodness
in fact aronian does have something to
play for tomorrow
needing to defeat magnus carlsen to
maybe have a chance
at first place gotta you had a very
interesting game today it seemed like
the high quality that you're used to
playing
what did you think about how the game
proceeded
well okay i played dash defense and
since i wanted to know what he prepared
for his line against magnus and actually
i didn't expect he repeated the line but
he did and um played knight season six
and he played bishop g3 and i started
thinking
but i think black had no problems in the
opening except that
uh for some reason i played this knight
of three exchange and then followed by
a5 which i thought was really weird
afterwards
because white gets all the free play in
the queen side
and he can just be strategically winning
if i didn't had this g5 g4 maneuver
but once i found g4 g4 or g5 g4 i think
black is okay and um
after that game was more or less equal
throughout the way
so at the end um it was just um
a scary looking thing but i think it was
an equal position now you say
scary-looking was here looking for white
right because it looked like you had
some attacking chances yes absolutely
i was scared looking for white were you
surprised that there was nothing
more coming out of there you did have a
queen coming in on g2 then f3
but it didn't seem as though you could
pressure his position at all not really
because uh
white is so solid i mean he has this
outpost on d5 and
um anytime i want to do something i'll
have to sacrifice and
uh white has enough enough resources for
defense and
um you know just i think it was a pretty
solid
equal game so you seem to be in a good
mood after the game i mean you
haven't been able to win a game yet at
the tournament and this
could have been one and now you have to
face nakamura tomorrow
what's your attitude seeing that this
wasn't your best tournament
well um i go and play every game like i
can and
uh you know
what okay i'm gonna play chess tomorrow
that's all i can to say you know
now obviously hikaru has to beat you
tomorrow in order
to have a chance to win the tournament
uh actually he doesn't have to he could
also draw and levon could win so there's
all kinds of
scenarios do you expect hikaru to come
with with all
swords and guns blazing i have no idea
but i expect myself to play a good game
tomorrow so
that's the only thing i at this point
i'm interested in you know
because obviously i'm in the last place
so my situation
is not going to change anytime soon but
the point is to play well at least one
game because so far in this tournament i
missed so many chances and so many
inaccuracies
i was not i'm not content with the level
of my play here so
okay all right well thanks for a
struggle today a good game
and we wish you the best in tomorrow's
game thank you maurice u.s champion
godakomski after
a pretty dynamic draw we'll see what
happens tomorrow
jen and yes see the quality game that
god has played today i mean he's playing
against the world's number two player
he has black he's under pressure and he
rebuffed
uh lavon's attempt so easily i mean you
think to yourself
wow what a great player he is and darn
it he's got nothing to show for it he's
in last place and struggling it's just
it's not fair well yeah i mean this
tournament is just so strong it's
amazing like
you look at kamsky's games and uh like
the game against carlson he didn't
really do much wrong and he lost uh
right
today's game he would have probably
scored a win against anybody
exactly it's just it really is
incredible and it just shows why
this is not just on paper the strongest
tournament in american history but also
i think it deserves that looking at the
quality of the games here
agreed absolutely yeah and we are going
to get a chance to speak with
oronion as well as as he
tries to win the tournament he still has
a chance and uh
even though um we said it earlier we
should remind players that there will be
a playoff if there's a tie for first
place
and then i'll start with a two-game
rapid match and then go
to a blitz armageddon so got it and the
question for me will be i'll have to ask
maurice
if levone considered this move rook b3
at the end
that was a cute little trappy move all
right we will find out i'm sure
grandmaster maurice ashley here with
grandmaster and number two in the world
lavon ironian
thanks shannon yaz well lavonne first of
all thank you for coming on the show
you had really almost to win today to
have a very strong
chance of taking first place but with a
draw you still haven't been knocked out
of
the first place chances what did you
feel going into the game and and how you
played as well today
yeah i was planning to you know get a
solid position and try
to push but then i actually missed his
g5
so and then the position became very
complex
i wasn't sure what's happening so
and after got this really strong with
queen f6 i got a bit worried
that came as a surprise to you we were
looking at it and thinking that white
had to start defending
yeah i thought that i should play rook
b3 but then i thought you know
it's a bit passive so i thought knight
h5 is risky but
you know i don't really have a big
choice so it either works or i just list
it didn't indeed look dangerous yasser
wants me to ask
you about this move in this moment rook
to b3 instead of
queen d1 with the idea of playing for e4
uh trapping the queen
it doesn't seem to win the game it just
seems to
force the draw did you take a look at
this or was your mind just simply on
queen d1 and muting all the
possibilities
yeah i actually thought that you know he
has this
because in this moment
i saw that ah sorry in this moment i saw
that he cannot take on g3
because i take because i play bishop d1
right
so i thought with king g7
and 2493 with king g7 if i play rook b3
bishop g3 here is possible that's a
sharp line but i think you're still
winning in that line wow
all right so well i didn't really have
much time to think over it
was i was i really in trouble here
because no no it's cause i felt that i'm
because i felt that i'm stabilizing yeah
you control the game definitely
but i'm feeling now that you've drawn
you have to beat
magnus carlsen tomorrow to to really
have
any chance of winning you also have the
black pieces
what are your thoughts about that oh
well i'll try
i'll try to see what happens you know
i i don't want to go home and
think about missing my chances so you'll
be going for the win tomorrow
i'll be playing my chest you know the
the way i play i
try to equalize first and then if i have
the chance play for a win
all right well good luck in your game
and thank you very much we'll see you
tomorrow
thanks world number two levon ironian
after a draw now needing a win with the
black pieces
to at least tie for first here and force
a play off
in the sink field cup jen and jazz the
great words of pal banco
when you're playing black first you
equalize then you play for the win
and that's the way it's done at the
highest levels well
how exciting it's a it's been a
four player uh double round robin
tournament but
three players will go into tomorrow's
uh game uh all hoping
to win the tournament and still a
possibility of a three-way tie for first
so still would be something right so
everything to play for for tomorrow the
final round
and what a weekend we have and we've got
that starting at 11 a.m
central time don't forget um one more
thought from grandmaster maurice ashley
yes now that i've got my math together
jen and yaz it does look as though
there's another alternative we should
think about
if nakamura wins tomorrow and carlson
loses nakamura wins the tournament
clear he doesn't even need a draw so
there's a lot to play for
lots of players at least nakamura and
aronian
desperate for a win carlson you know
would love
to put the hammer down and win the game
and just prove
that he's not only the number one player
in the world but a deserving
candidate for the world championship
title which he'll be playing for
later this year so an exciting round six
a foot
it'll be amazing i can't wait i can't
wait either and
uh so many possibilities we could have a
playoff just between nakamura and
carlson we could have a three-way
play-off we could have carlson at first
lavon
uh the the possibilities are endless
but you'll only know if you join us
tomorrow that's right so join us
tomorrow don't forget
11 11 a.m central here in st louis
and 12 eastern for those of you on the
east coast
and uh i'm jennifer shahady and i'm
signing off for
grand masters yasser sarawan maurice
ashley thanks to all of our gm
guests today starting with gary kasparov
and also from
two grand masters from webster
university we had so much fun and we
hope you will join us
tomorrow
you